her truth or is that is that really how
the world is this or I could okay could
you let me finish yes or I could or I
could walk down the street and be like
hmm it's fine and I could see this study
and I could see a data point that that's
probably manipulate that is manipulated
that says one out of four women were
great right you remember that one that
was going around a couple years ago and
even even when that came out I was like
no that's off like because what I see in
the world I don't think men are out
there great I'm gonna you know YouTube
friendly graping women like that so
um yeah that's that's how I put it but
let's go back to that woman you were
talking about yeah the interview right
yeah let's say that was her experience
that every time she goes out and you
know she yeah goes somewhere she gets
grapes or yeah but she doesn't she
doesn't I know she does it right he
doesn't let's say that was her
experience would she be okay to make a
statement but would she be okay to make
a statement okay if that was actually
happening everywhere no no it's a hood
no if that was actually happening
everywhere then sure but it's not but
I'm saying that's not real so like a lot
of times to like to prove a point like
you make up a scenario that's not real
in order to prove the point but that's
not that's not real like I think I think
you can go like if that was happening
where everywhere she goes she was
getting raped I would give her yeah you
could say that like if you because it
wouldn't just be her if she was getting
graped everywhere she go then I would
know multiple people it's like okay they
could say that when like men are hitting
women right and you could give me a data
point but my gut is going to tell me
that data point is off because I know a
bunch of men that have been hit by a
woman but I don't know one woman that's
been actually hit by a dude and I know a
bunch of girls that like said they were
hit by dudes but then turns out they
were both hitting each other so so how
are you gonna be this so I think the
point is like a lot of times data is
manipulated and you might not be able to
explain it like in that moment but you
just know like I just think everyone has
a level of like common sense and you
could argue you know that's my truth but
I just I like Thomas Sobel says it best
when it's like like you make the best
Decisions by looking at what's around
you
so that's that's how I put it
that makes sense that makes sense I
actually agree with you yeah with that
one I was just being The Devil's
Advocate but
again I'll go back to the point that
when they're trying to help these men
Yeah by saying by bringing up certain
stats and saying certain things you know
a lot of times not a lot of times
there's I've seen multiple
multiplications spoken about
Christianity or spoken about um the
Muslim right it's the housing Church
yeah Muslim faith and I've seen sneaker
do exactly yeah
but again those they're bringing up
things that are completely just
disagree with the way of life because
they'll talk about how in in Islam it's
okay to have multiple words but actually
you know there's a caveat that yeah
foreign
but generally monogamy is encouraged and
what's it called adultery and any form
of fornication is punished by a hundred
lashes are you sure because I met a
couple people on my show that had
multiple and I don't think their wife
was abused or anything so this is
obviously it's literally very so easy
search but I've spoken to some was right
before doing this yeah Justin I don't
know yeah so that could be true I don't
know and and then with Christianity it
always mention things like oh look in
the if you look into Old Testament
um this happened and this happened when
in actuality in actuality in the Bible
it doesn't necessarily say that this was
right it doesn't say this was wrong it
just tells you how well in the Old
Testament it doesn't say it was wrong or
right it just tells you this is how it
was this is what was happening it
doesn't tell me what's right and then in
the New Testament which is meant to
override the Old Testament it literally
tells you no you're not meant to be
doing this so I don't understand why
they tried to use that
for men yes yeah I mean I don't push it
on my channel no I'm saying like I don't
yeah I know that was actually one of my
biggest great like I didn't really like
how they pushed that when I first got
into red pill but I don't know the more
I get into it I'm like if all these
girls are putting their on a silver
platter can you blame them it's like
putting a piece of meat in front of the
hunter it takes a hell of types a hell
of a dude to turn it down when they're
getting on demand like in the top 20
percent of guys and they do work the
last 15 years to get there for a lot I
mean some dudes are just born into it
but like I I I'm not saying I I condone
it and they should but I'm just saying I
understand
you know but my my main issue is the
fact that if you want to be pushing A
Certain narrative if you want to be
saying that you're factual and that
you're using stats to back up your
statements at least make sure your
statements are correct or the things
that you're using actually backs up the
way you think it it does so if you're
using the viable yeah if you use a Bible
if you're using the Quran make sure it
actually says that rather than just
um just saying stuff in order to one get
an audience that you think will like
this sort of message you think that you
think freshman patius's audience is
religious
is a very smart man and I think
some of the stuff he says in order if
you see how his stance on religion has
changed over the last few months yeah
and the stuff he said about I think he's
trying to reach out to certain people on
that side of video because he's not
going to get the people on the left he
won't he's going to get more
conservative people and they tend to be
more
um lean towards religion and so I think
he knows what he's doing when he bring
when he says stuff like oh I I'm I
believe in God and you know whoever is
sarcastic I really like sometimes he'll
say it but like when he was on that date
with Cheyenne Rebels yeah and he's like
I'm a man
that was definitely a joke but I mean in
more serious
um in more serious yeah and
conversations he's actually spoken about
how he thinks faith is important for men
it's important for well I mean he did
have a video of him cheating on his
girlfriends in front of each other so
you know I I probably would I would
agree with you I don't think they come
off as that religious so I would believe
that they got the Bible wrong
I would believe it what's your
especially kind of funny like the Vlog
if you're going to look it up I'm good
I'm good we're like crying at the party
I'm like what the it's like you
like threw a party with all of his
girlfriends that is just sad I'm like I
wouldn't do that that's actually a good
another good segue but then it's like if
you date that guy what did you expect
exactly that's another good segment to
what I was gonna say because you know do
you think high value men
should no no do you think high vitamin
can exercise options
um I mean they they can like but I don't
I don't even like to say should like I'd
prefer to be in a family I think it's
more stable for a family if the dad
doesn't cheat
um because my dad was in that category
and like I'm very proud of the fact that
my dad doesn't drink doesn't smoke
doesn't cheat like he's just a really
good dude and gives me someone to look
up to but
I I don't know I it's like if a dude's
worked for 20 years to do this and the
girl agrees to it like who who am I tell
you what to do I think yeah I think that
makes sense right I think what you just
said makes sense yeah the person the
relationship you're with
um says okay yeah but or if you're
dating an NBA player and you get cheated
on I don't feel bad for you uh gee like
that girl Jason Derulo's chick who's on
Instagram saying Oh no I got sorry oh no
I got cheated on boo you're dating Jason
Derulo what did you think was gonna
happen he was a hoe before he met you
he went to you he's still it's like it's
like when you when you wife a hoe it's
like she was a hoe before you met you
yeah like it's the same sorry okay it's
just it's just like because what bothers
me is girls go in acting all innocent oh
I had no idea but